[Music]
you're here for the 10 day retreat
us 2.0 i certainly am
apparently i'm in need of some fixing
welcome
to tranquil and house the people who
come here
they come to heal i don't want to suffer
you're already suffering
breakfast seven lunch noon dinner 7 30.
and how many guests are there nine total
wellness retreats there's such utter
crap and yet here you are
all right let's go meditate
i want you all now to close your eyes
you want to get well you want to heal
surrender yourself to me
i am gonna fix you
so what's your story i have one
everybody has a story
that's why she picked us what do you
mean she picked us
we compliment each other's demons
[Music]
i'm not sure i'm really supposed to be
here
my vote is give this thing a shot open
up a new door
some doors are meant to stay closed
yeah it could be a real [ __ ] show what
the hell do i know right
this is particularly volatile group
let's start the protocol
i don't think they're ready
it's perfectly safe i've been feeling
unlike myself the wheels
starting to fall
she picked nine people who needed to be
in a place where they would try anything
she wanted
have you all gone mad
there's nothing to fear
because this
it's gonna change everything this is
where i want to be it's masha batshit or
she the real deal
[Music]
you